The rules that I just showed you were
great for validating a single property.
But to deal with malformed
data on a larger scale,
you're also going to need to
validate object structure.
With Firebase rules, you can first
require that certain properties must
exist in the object as well as validate
that those properties are the only
properties that exist in the object.
To require the existence to certain
properties you could use either
the hasChild or hasChildren method.
The hasChildren method is if you want
to verify for multiple properties and
you can see it being used here.
This rule requires that the name,
email timestampJoined and
hasloggedInWithPassword are properties
that are included within any object that
is saved at this location.
hasChildren is pretty simple to use.
It takes an array of property
key names as shown here.
And it's placed directly in the object.
Now hasChildren requires that these
properties exist, but it doesn't say
that those are the only properties
that can exist within the object.
If you want to do that,
you can add the following code.
You make a wildcard variable in
the top level the object and
set its validation to false.
So how does this work?
To understand going on, you have to
understand how wildcard variables work.
When you write an object to the
database, the properties of that object
will be matched with all of
these named variables first.
So if an object that saved at this
location has a name property,
it will check the validation
rules in here.
If it has the email property it will
check the validation rules in here.
Now if that happens,
as in if there is an extra property,
it immediately validates to false.
So two things.
Note first that there's nothing
special about the name other.
It can really be dollar sign anything.
Also, for this to work,
you have to explicitly list out
all the correct properties.
Using both hasChildren and
a wildcard variable,
you can be sure that your data is
structured exactly how it's meant to be.